you must have seen coins and Nails sink  in the water right but large metallic  bodies at the same time like ships can  stay afloat why is that the case  so coins are made up of metal and it is  a very dense substance and it's packed  within a very small volume and thus it  sinks and ships are designed to have a  large flat bottom so the water pushes up  the bottom of the ship with a force  called the buoyant force if the point  force is greater than the weight of the  ship what will happen the ship will  steer float and if the ship is heavier  than the point force then the ship will  sink but we design ships such that the  buoyant force is greater and that is the  reason why ships do not sink due to  point C okay can you name me some more  materials which can float and sink in  the water comment down below subscribe  to our Channel